[Music]
hey what's up guys i'm kbhd here and
welcome to the sequel to the previous
video so the part two which is the mini
factory tour with elon i want to preface
it just with the intro by saying first
of all it is really difficult to shoot
good video in that factory as you'll
both see in here it's extremely loud and
extremely busy so this is more of just
like a walking around and having fun and
checking things out uh it's it's
actually probably just like 15 or 20
of the actual model s and x factory
process it's not the whole thing it's
mostly just elon showing us around and
in fact i didn't even really say much
during this interview was more just like
a i was kind of like a kid in the matrix
just kind of absorbing everything and
then it also kind of cuts abruptly at
the end when elon basically gets pulled
into his next meeting but i still
thought it was a ton of fun and worth
sharing and also i should mention this
entire video shoot this production would
not be possible without my buddy john
from the tld channel and his crew who
helped with audio who were the muscle
with the steadicam he has an entire
behind-the-scenes video of this process
on his channel i'll link that right
below so if you want to check that out
after watching this in part one feel
free
but until the next one this is your mini
tour of the tesla factory with elon
enjoy one that loops back and like i
said just gives gives us access to the
central corridor yeah so it's really
just like lifting it up and over
so
the car that ends up here came all the
way down this previous yeah yeah exactly
so like these robots are really just to
give us that uh like through through
access okay yeah so so it's gonna pick
it up and transfer it to the other robot
yeah
but i think like you know like a design
improvement we should do is like really
just the one robot just passes to the
other robot um just pick it up yeah
there's a third one above us yeah it's
like it puts it on a table the table
rotates it's like like you would do is
if we did the sofa we would just have
that giant robot pass it to that giant
robot fair yeah hand off yeah
it's like
thousands of like little things like
that that help improve production
general assembly kind of operates in
kind of a use so it goes cars coming
over there go all the way down here and
then way that way
and uh you can see the car get
progressively more complex as it goes
down the general assembly line what does
it look like when it starts this side of
the assembly line oh we can go there
there you go there let's go should we
start there so at the beginning
but here you can get a good sense for
there's like like general assembly is
what i was talking about as being really
well suited to people okay uh because
you got a lot of weird things that you
got to put together like you know like
look at some of these um
you know assemblies they're like like
it's pretty hard for a robot to like
connect this on that makes sense yeah
it's
you know like
depending upon how it comes out of the
box it could be like in a little
different position
but it's pretty easy for somebody like
oh it's like i just need to move it like
an inch you know bolt it in it's
probably really hard to write software
to kind of know to adapt in all these
different ways yeah so you try to order
if you try to have the robot do this you
gotta have like a complicated vision
system and then like the vision system
folds out it's like it's not quite right
that's the hard part we have a robot in
our studio that moves the camera around
and the hardest part is when it falls
yeah you need a person there to know
what to do exactly so hopefully that
doesn't happen much
um
like
for parts that are that are complicated
and friendly like wiring harnesses are
especially difficult you see how like
the wiring harness kind of needs to
snake uh through the car yeah it's
certainly like like winding like a snake
through the car yeah you gotta like poke
it through holes and and do diverse
things that's super difficult for a
robot see like how they're like putting
the uh
there's a part of the air conditioning
system there right
um so you use like a little bit of
mechanical assistance with the winch and
whatnot but then it's pretty
straightforward for the guys to just
like get that in there and then like if
they see there's an issue with the part
then like they say oh this product's got
a problem like we'll put it over here
for
to you know um to get fixed like this is
like semi lines like moving slowly yeah
so like moves along
and then if
you know it gives people like time to
get things done like you can like stand
on this and i think you mentioned like
the the speed of the car coming out the
other side is like one mile an hour or
something like that yeah it's super slow
you want to speed this up right yeah
it's not even one mile an hour it's even
slower than that right now but for sx
but for
for three it's like getting close to a
mile an hour okay okay um
but walking speeds three miles an hour
so it's like only one third walking
speed at one mile an hour all right but
you can see like when you look on the
inside of the car you see like how many
little complicated little pieces there
are a lot um
you know the things that are meant to uh
for installation corrosion protection
um airbags
uh
road noise
like it's all the stuff that gets put in
here yeah you can see like these are
like the side airbags here
okay um
i must feel i think it's like pretty
cool like most people never see like the
inside of the car yeah there's a million
things you never see driving the car
every day this is like sorry guys
starting to rough
[Music]
if you don't mind being on like on like
you know the internet and stuff is that
cool
all right youtube's small i actually
don't interrupt your work but um you
know it's like you see like how like
there's like a lot of tricky pieces
and
like if for a person like this is like
doable straightforward yeah you know it
takes a bit of training out of speed
whatever but like once once you like
um basically like
like a pro human can do this super well
and it's like hard for the robots to do
that but when we go to the like the body
welding i'll show you like what's like
what's a robot good at and you'll see
like there's tons of robots like tons of
people here tons of robots there um but
there's so much complexity and variation
here
um you gotta grab those wires when it
comes through especially here
at this door so so like
this is the car with like less stuff in
it and then it goes it's you know and
we'll see the beginning of it right and
then that then it goes all the way
around gets more and more stuff added
and does it end at the end well general
assembly ends probably somewhere down
there yeah okay so
um but you can essentially see the car
get progressively more complex as we add
more parts to it
you know this place uh used to employ
like about 5 000 people and now we got
like we could we got 10 000 people just
in this location yeah so what we do is
we have like tons of shuttles and like
three cars ride sharing yeah uh we got
the barrier rapid transit station
finally like went went up
um so just like trying to get people
here is is a big challenge yeah what is
this
oh this is
actually like this is one of my favorite
dumb robots okay
yeah i'm a fan right now it's pretty
cool um so like there's a lot of fancy
robots
uh that like but they have like lots of
issues they break down all the time
those these little guys are super great
but like
they follow this magnetic stripe
see basically it's like super easy to
program you don't even need to be a
programmer
because you just like lay down the the
mag stripe and it'll follow it yeah just
follows the back stripe and then it's
got proximity sensors in the front so
if if it sees an obstacle or seems like
something in the way it just stops and
then as soon as something moves out of
the way it just keeps going
you know just like there's this like
little thing all day long like a little
train like you're talking about robots
faulting out and one of the
it's like that's like where
like actually um
doing things manually can can actually
be more um
more efficient because if you have like
a lot of complicated robots particularly
if you have a 24 7 operation like we
have with model 3 uh then if robot
faults out you're going to have 24 7
like advanced robot technicians make
sense and then if the robot like
accidentally crashes and like breaks a
fixture then it's like man okay now
right now we've got the line we've got
lined down that's what i have to read
alert and then i get pulled on my cell
phone at two in the morning and it's
like not a lot of time i fly apart in
from germany it's like we literally had
that two days ago do you have to when
you get new robots do you build the
robots or do you order them in and
program them
so
there's like different classes there's
many many different types of robots so
the like the giant robot they were still
lifting the car yeah it's like that's
that that is a catalog item but then we
have to program the the motions right
and then and the end effector
is that it's custom so the interface
that picks up the car drops it off
that's a custom made thing okay so it's
kind of like you kind of like buy this
like powerful arm but it's just like
having an arm stuck in the ground and
then you're like okay what does the arm
do you got to tell it everything to do
yeah okay and then you got to put
sensors on it and put fixtures
but that's like kind of like that robot
over there uh that's also one of like
the ones that picks up the car oh uh by
the way these are like named after x-men
oh yeah i forgot about that
um just x-men i feel like
like marvel and x-men is like gotta
start to run out of names yeah yeah
actually turns out a lot of x-men yeah
okay
so you can see like this is like quite a
beast of a robot you can't just buy that
robot
in this case it's a fanuc robot
um
and uh you can buy the robot but then
the end effector that's carrying the car
is something that's custom and then you
gotta do the programming and the like
wire in the sensors and that kind of
thing so to the the level of precision
of this massive robot is it to like
as far as repeatable action is it
literally the same path everything yeah
plus or minus an inch oh no it's a
centimeter it's better than that
for a big robot there's a little less
precision than a smaller robot yeah but
say a medium-sized robot will be
accurate to
0.2.3 millimeters oh okay what is the
most popular
paint color
coming through here
that's black black yeah it actually
varies by
country um
like
uh watch out there's a dumb robot coming
through oh yeah this guy's like pretty
pretty cool like what
[Music]
all right this can go wrong i don't know
you trust him more than i do
yeah okay
okay all right good job good job robot
yeah i i see a lot of silver
and i see a lot of white model x
just in new jersey black and white are
the two most colors are too much popular
colors okay um
the white micro are
like black slide is is slightly more
popular than white in the us but in like
europe it's way more popular like white
is a very rare color in europe for a car
okay um in the u.s it's like it's it's
about even with with black black and
white the two most common colors yeah
and here you can see
battery pack
this is like to be like a mating station
for the battery pack oh this is
literally connecting the battery to the
car
here you can see it's like a combination
of manual automatic
so it's like they're lining it up it's
like yeah exactly it's so
it's it's done primarily by the robot
system by the automated system but then
you've got a person just making sure
that the fine tuning is there gotcha how
do you feel about matt
matte or satin colors
about that a lot i actually like the
aesthetics of matte
it's really tricky
to to repair a mat so
like yes you can polish it out with that
um if you get like a little ding it's
really hard to then rematch the so it
looks like an even mat yeah you can't
just like you know that's fair point
yeah um so it's it's doable it's
it's something actually we would like to
do that in the future um
but um like right now for example like
the paint shop is really operating at
full tilt so
adding any complexity to the paint shop
we're definitely wise right now but
right i think it'll be a cool thing to
do in the future but these are the sub
assemblies
so you can see like the front rear drive
units being bolted up and the self
assemblies then feed the main assembly
line
these are a long assembly line
oh yeah
well it's and it's it's integrating uh
snx okay and it's making about 2 000
cars a week is model 3 entirely
completely separate i guess yes inside
the same building but separate
whole process the only place where model
3 and snx come together is in the paint
shop so the paint shop is processing s3
and x um simultaneously down the same
line
but otherwise general assembly is
separate body separate
um
yeah everything else is different so
just the paint shop where they come
together you've mentioned you've slept
in the factory to be able to
immediately like diagnose problems and
hands-on fix what's not right
what type of things happen that you can
immediately fix
or immediately take action on actually
last last three months last year i
mostly spent at gigafactory
trying to
help fix the battery production it's a
module production
and it's just
it's a lot of little things like
looking at at each
uh at each little little tiny part each
process say is the process necessary
it's like because the best part is no
part best part a process is no process
and occasionally at the design level you
think something's necessary but then
turns out it's not so just like making
sure connect connecting between design
um and manufacturing uh make sure to
make sure we close the loop on that
just saying like hey is this if it let's
say it's a it's like it's a lot of real
simple stuff but it's like times times a
thousand yeah so
if we have like a automated vault driver
going in like what's the rpm the torque
settings for the vault driver um can we
make that go faster uh usually usually
can unnecessary movements
um
like like for example i actually don't
really like the fact that we lift the
cars over and and back
ideally that would be a robot handoff
getting rid of a middle stage yeah
exactly because the middle side what's
wrong with it's like putting it on a
turntable and then the tune table is
rotating and the other robot's picking
it up it's actually the problem is like
sometimes the tune table breaks down wow
and and so okay so it's like okay let's
eliminate the turntable and just have a
robot go to robot um and then you don't
have like uh turntable breakage to
consider so it's a lot of minimizing
things that can go wrong
and maximizing the efficiency of these
simple things i guess just like
like design necessity of every part of
it and every process yeah uh just the
speed at which um
especially the robots are going um other
are there any is there any unnecessary
movement in the production line that
that isn't value-added like we're
actually doing something yeah um
like replacing
elements of the production system that
are not
not needed or redundant